welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gayle King with Tony to copal and
Anthony Mason the British royal family
is reeling from an extraordinary new
rift involving Prince Harry and Meghan
Markel the couple as you may have heard
now is stepping down as senior members
of the family will split their time
between the UK and North America one
British tabloid calls it Mex it Mark
Phillips is at Buckingham Palace with
more on this story
market doesn't seem like the royal
family is very happy with a couples
decision to put it mildly
no gale good morning well you know pick
a pick a reaction disappointed hurt
angry incandescent all of those words
have been used to describe the royal
family's reaction here to make it an
airy statement it turns out it's not so
much what they did it's how they did it
Megan and Harry were known to be unhappy
now everybody is they had been
discussing how to distance themselves
from the Royal whirlwind but went ahead
and issued their statement on their own
and without clearing it with the upper
reaches of the royal food chain
particularly the Queen
we intend to step back as senior members
of the royal family their statement said
we now plan to balance our time between
the United Kingdom and North America the
palace countered discussions are at an
early stage the royal family said these
are complicated issues code for not so
fast kids this is not how we do things
around here for Megan and Harry it was
like a declaration of independence they
were just back in London after a
carefree six-week Holliday escape in
Canada family time with young Archie
away from the palace pressure cooker
they went to the Canadian Embassy in
London to say thanks
and they wanted more it's been a stormy
time for the couple since that sunny
wedding day 20 months ago Megan may have
been a TV star used to the public glare
but as her friends had warned her
nothing prepared an American especially
one with a biracial background for the
kind of scrutiny she would endure my
british-run said to me
I'm sure he's great but because the
British tabloids will destroy your life
Harry who had lived through his mother
Princess Diana's battles with the
tabloid press became increasingly
defensive I always tell my family I know
I have a family to protect it's been
described by royal watchers like Roy
Anika as a palace civil war I think
Harry Megan going their own way on it
have really really put the cat amongst
the pigeons and have caused perhaps an
irreparable rift with senior members of
the royal family including the Queen it
hasn't taken along for Harry and Megan
to go from being a breath of fresh air
the Royals desperately needed to
becoming a storm that threatens to blow
the roof off the House of Windsor so
from brexit tomb exit as the way it's
being described here but this is
uncharted territory how will it work the
companies say the couple say they want
to be financially independent will she
go back to work will he what can he do
it is uncharted territory gale and
nobody knows uncharted territory seems a
little bumpy right now yes I'll say okay
Mark Phillips at Buckingham Palace we
thank you
you